on a des jeunes qui ont vu la
pornographie sur des écrans à 4 ans 5
ans simplement parce que les parents ne
surveillaient pas n'avaient pas mis de
contrôle parentaux et n'était pas
présent à ce moment-là l'âge moyen
aujourd'hui de visionnage de contenu
pornographiques c'est 11 ans aujourd'hui
on est face à ce qu'on peut appeler le
fléau de la pornographie où on a la
majorité des jeunes donc plus de 82 %
des mineurs qui ont été exposés au
contenu pornographique en ligne et la
pornographie d'autres fois la
pornographie il y a 20 ans c'est pas la
pornographie d'aujourd'hui qui est
accessible de manière illimitée gratuite
infinie extrêmement facilement pour les
jeunes aujourd'hui il y a une étude qui
a été faite au Royaume-Uni selon
laquelle 75% des parents pensaient que
leurs enfants ne regardaient pas de
pornographie or 53% de ses enfants là
regardez de la pornographie une grande
majorité plus de 60% tombe sur la
pornographie de manière involontaire ça
peut être soit parce que un copain leur
en a montré dans la cour de récré une
soirée d'anniversaire ou autre mais ça
peut aussi et surtout être par les
réseaux sociaux Tik Tok Instagram
Messenger où il va y avoir des images
qui vont leur être envoyées de manière
complètement invol et il ne s'attendent
pas à les recevoir forcément et par les
pop-up les réseaux sociaux facilitent
l'accès à la pornographie dans le sens
où tous les jeunes aujourd'hui ont un
compte c'est pas forcément un loisir
mais avant c'est clairement un
divertissement qui est venu
ultra répandu aujourd'hui on peut avoir
accès à la pornographie de manière
illimitée 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
donc on va avoir deux élèves qui vont
avoir un smartphone et ils vont se
rassembler à 10 12 autour de ces deux
smartphones et regarder des films
pornographiques dessus quelle diverses
conséquences le visionnage de contenu
pornographique a-t-il chez les jeunes
parmi les dégâts il va d'abord y avoir
simplement le fait que l'enfant va
s'enfermer s'isoler dans le fait d'avoir
vu une image qui l'a potentiellement
choqué et face à laquelle il a eu de la
sidération il a très souvent ressenti à
la fois du dégoût et du plaisir de la
culpabilité et de l'excitation très
souvent ça va entraîner plus de
visionnage peu développer une forme
d'adtion et on observe très
régulièrement des jeunes de 14 15 16 ans
qui ont une véritable dépendance à la
pornographie et ça énormément de
conséquences à la fois physique
psychiques relationnelles physiques on
peut parler de dysfonctionnement
rectiles de baisse de libido
psychologique on peut aussi parler de
tout ce qui tourne autour de l'isolation
de la dépression la relation entre les
sexes ne se fait plus de la même manière
de la d'une manière saine mais face à ce
déferlement de contenu y a-t-il des
solutions envisageables redonner la
responsabilité au site qui diffuse du
contenu pornographique et faire en sorte
que eux reconnaissent que il y a une
protection vis-à-vis des mineurs une loi
qu'il faut respecter ensuite il y a tout
ce qui tourne autour de la protection on
peut protéger les mineurs avec certains
outils qui existent les contrôles
parentaux qui sont sur les opérateurs
mobiles et les opérateurs fixes il va y
avoir tout ce qui est l'auteur de pop-up
donc il y a toute la dimension protégées
mais ça ça suffit pas il faut vraiment
préparer et prévenir en amont il y a
tout ce qui tourne autour de l'éducation
à la vie affective relationnelle et
sexuelle de l'enfant et c'est essentiel
d'ouvrir ce dialogue pour faire en sorte
que parler de sexualité à la maison ça
ne soit pas tabou j'ai un exemple très
concret
un jeune qui regardait de la
pornographie et ses parents sont entrés
dans sa chambre ont vu qu'il regardait
de la pornographie se sont arrêtés et
sont repartis et ils n'en n'ont jamais
parlé le jeune a vrai véritablement
senti que il y avait un jugement il y
avait un tabou il y avait quelque chose
qu'il avait fait quelque chose de mal et
il a eu ce sentiment de culpabilité il y
a vraiment une urgence à la fois de la
part du gouvernement c'est une question
de santé publique il y a une urgence au
niveau des établissements pour qu'ils
mettent vraiment en place les cours
d'éducation à la vie affective
relationnelle et sexuelle et une urgence
de la part des parents à la fois de
protéger leurs enfants avec des outils
très concrets et pratiques mais
également de pouvoir ouvrir le dialogue
auprès de leurs enfants à ce sujet et
faire en sorte que la sexualité ne soit
plus un tabou
[Musique]